the x-men can finally be used in the MCU
ever since they went back to their home
at Disney and Marvel Studios thanks to
the Disney Fox Dale coming to a
completion but of course the biggest
question that everybody has been asking
since the deal has been completed is
when are we going to see these new
characters enter the MCU
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we're all wondering when are we going to
see the x-men the Fantastic Four the
Silver Surfer and Galactus enter the MCU
there have been talks that the Fantastic
Four will be coming before the x-men but
nobody really knows but at this year's
San Diego comic-con during Marvel's
panel Marvel President Kevin Feige did
name-drop the Fantastic Four and mutants
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about a
mutant
[Applause]
but all that stuff's been rumored you've
heard about rumors
so plans have clearly started over at
Disney and Marvel Studios to introduce
these new characters in the MCU now
Kevin Feige has mentioned that it will
probably be a handful of years until we
see the x-men in the MCU but that
doesn't mean that Marvel hasn't already
begun working on the movie that is going
to introduce the x-men to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in fact we have just
learned that Marvel has indeed been
working on the first movie that is going
to introduce the mutants so I'll talk
about this exciting news in this video
first real quick I just want to say
thank you to everybody that has been
following me we just hit 500,000
subscribers and I am so grateful for
every single one of you I want to thank
everybody who has supported me up until
this point of course I'll be making a
thank-you video later on and of course
it will announce the winner of the Xbox
one or ps4 giveaway but seriously thank
you all once again and if you're still
looking to win a console I'll be doing a
new giveaway soon and also click the
link in the description for your chance
to win a Nintendo switch so this new
exclusive about the x-men reboot coming
to the MCU comes from full circle cinema
calm and according to you full circle
cinema calm the reboot of the x-men
could have a twist to it and according
to their report Kevin Feige and
everybody else at Marvel and Disney are
considering having people of color
portray both Magneto and Professor X now
this probably won't change much with
Charles Xavier because he was simply
born in your to a wealthy family so they
could have any person of color play that
role without changing anything about who
Charles Xavier is however Marvel Studios
could make some changes to magneto but
the reason for it really has more to do
with the timeline of the MCU Erich was
born in the 1920s to a Jewish family and
during World War two he was sent to a
Nazi concentration camp in Auschwitz
well the current MCU takes place in 2023
which would mean Erich is almost a
hundred years old and that is probably
not something that Marvel's going to do
he may be a mutant but he's not immortal
he's not like one of the Eternals who
can live for thousands and thousands of
years so the studio may take some
Liberty
in changing his backstory just a little
bit to make him fit in the current MCU
now the reason that the studio wants a
person of color to play both Professor X
and Magneto is pretty obvious Marvel is
going to have to make the x-men that are
coming to the MCU very different than
the Fox x-men Marvel is not going to
really want any association with the Fox
x-men at all and for good measure
because most of the fanbase doesn't
really like the last few x-men films
that were released by Fox so they're
going to have to make their x-men pretty
different so it seems like the studio is
going to make Magneto and Professor X
played by persons of color to make that
difference this is also a really big
part of Kevin Feige plan for the future
of the MCU he said that the future is
going to be more diverse groups of
people playing characters in the MCU but
let me know what you think about this
news what do you think about Professor X
and Magneto being played by persons of
color do you think that it would change
the story at all and who would you like
to see play these characters let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
also don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
x-men and the MCU don't forget to click
the link in the description for your
chance to win a Nintendo switch and also
don't forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof